Let's check in with our caller from the eight
one five area code.
Who's calling today from eight one five.
Hi, this is Jonathan.
I'm from Rockford, Illinois.
Jonathan, uh, hi.
Uh, I just had a quick question about on,
so considering the current state of our, like,
political climate, particularly like with
the DNC, you know, trying to rally against
Bernie and obviously the ideological differences
with, uh, from Republicans with Democrats.
Um, would you see like, hypothetically if
Bernie was to become president, do you think
his term would even be successful considering
that there's so many people going against
them, both on the left and right.
Um, and so like his policies are like Medicare
for all, um, you know, universal education,
all that.
Um, what do you mean be successful in trying
to convince other people to sign on to that
even if he were to be president?
Well, I've taught when I've talked about this
before in the context of health care, I was
absolutely crushed by a huge portion of the
Bernie supporters in my audience.
And remember, I'm voting for Bernie in the
primary.
Um, no, you're absolutely right, which is
that, uh, if it's Bernie versus Trump, Bernie's
the right choice and we vote for Bernie and
hopefully Bernie wins and he gets as much
done as possible.
And he will get some things done.
But when you have a significant part of the
democratic Senate, not in favor of Medicare
for all, when you have the filibuster, when
you have all of these other things, of course
Bernie is not going to get everything done
that he promises.
And that's no different than any candidate
every, every candidate has.
Trump is going to do a wall.
He was going to do new healthcare, he was
going to eliminate the deficit and eventually
pay off the debt.
Like he's not doing any of that stuff.
Now.
Those things were completely unrealistic to
begin with.
But needless to say, it wouldn't be a new
thing that someone is brought into office
and their ambition is bigger than what they
can accomplish.
That is a perfectly realistic and sensible
thing to talk about.
The question though is what can we get done
and making sure that we do it, but you're
completely right.
Anybody who argues that you're being a defeatist
is being completely unrealistic.
Yeah, totally.
I agree.
Cause you know, I don't think that, you know,
you have to be realistic, especially right
now.
You know, you gotta take your victories where
you can.
And, um, so I totally agree.
And I also wanted to ask, um, for, so like,
obviously with the rise of Bloomberg, um,
and his like, you know, he has obviously he's
been the mayor of New York and he has some
political experience.
Um, but for someone like Trump or you know,
Tom Stier, um, do you think it's time, and
I know this probably would never happen, but
that we update like qualifications for the
presidency that involve like maybe having
some type of political experience holding
some type of office or you know, just maybe
updating what we have already?
Um,
no I don't.
So first of all it would be very difficult
to add new requirements, but I actually, I,
I don't think that political experience should
be required.
I would like it if the electorate was more
informed about if you lack political experience,
what other sort of experience would be a good
replacement.
I don't think being a reality show host and
using your dad's money to still run a business
that goes bankrupt a bunch of times.
Like that doesn't qualify for me, but I wouldn't
want to add more requirements.
The only things I would consider adding are
maybe we should have a president, presidential
candidates, major party, presidential candidates
undergo a full cognitive assessment.
And I think that that particularly this presidency
has made a relevant, but no, I wouldn't add
more requirements about, I don't believe it
would be constitutional.
And, uh, it would be very, very difficult
to achieve.
And I don't think it's the right thing either.
Okay.
All right.
Fair enough.
All right, well those are all my questions,
so thank you, David.
All right, thanks.
I appreciate the phone call very, very much.
That is going to do it for today.
I do apologize.
I wasn't able to get to everyone, but it is
great that there are more people calling in
than the number that I can get to because
otherwise it would [inaudible]
be very, very sad.
We will take calls again.
We will take a quick break and then I will
be back with much more right after this